haben sie sich nicht auch schon mal
gefragt liebe zuschauer mensch warum
wohne ich denn eigentlich nicht längst
im eigenheim mit garten oder in der
eigentumswohnung vielleicht meine eltern
meine großeltern die kollegen die ein
paar jahre älter sind da aber die preise
so massiv gestiegen sind es ist
entsetzlich wenn sie mal schauen bei den
einschlägigen
immobilienportalen früher wie erinnerung
ist auch noch eine zwei zimmer wohnung
in berlin britz oder 60.000 70.000 euro
rund 380.000 euro je nachdem natürlich
wo sie regional gucken aber das ist ein
massen für ein drastischer preisanstieg
und deswegen kommen viele menschen auch
aus der mittelschicht in deutschland
nicht mehr ins wohneigentum das ist für
viele vollkommen unerschwinglich
geworden aber woran liegt denn das
manche behaupten jetzt ja ja die jungen
leute die nehmen gern was und coffee to
go auf die hand mit ist ja kein wunder
wo man so lebt da kann man sich
natürlich kein haus leisten dass
vernebelt die wahren ursachen die wahre
ursache ist nämlich die politik der
europäischen zentralbank an der spitze
christine lagarde an der iss an der ezb
spitze die nämlich den nullzins
geschaffen bzw aufrecht erhält der
nullzins wir müssen noch mal klar sagen
viele haushalte viele staaten in europa
vor allem in südeuropa sind schwer
verschuldet zum beispiel italien und die
cam wirklich an den rande eines starts
ruins wenn jetzt der leitzins stieg
deswegen macht die ezb das nicht hält
den leitzins schön auf null dadurch
verwerten dadurch steigen aber die
hauspreise ganz massiv die sogenannten
vermögenswerte werden immer teurer auch
aktien und das verschärft jetzt eben
ganz massiv die situation auch in
deutschland die soziale spaltung die
dadurch deutlich verschärfe das darf
nicht sein es kann nicht sein dass
südeuropäer zum beispiel auf kosten der
deutschen mittelschicht leben dass die
ezb die deutschen im grunde in die armut
zwingt das muss aufhören und ich möchte
auch dazu aufrufen sprechen sie mal
darüber sprechen tauschen sie sich aus
mit kollegen darüber sagen sie das mal
das muss endlich spread the word die
leute müssen das endlich verstehen
diesen mechanismus nullzins bedeutet wir
kommen nicht mehr ins eigenheim das ist
der preis dafür und der ist viel zu hoch
das muss aufhören und deshalb auch ganz
klarer appell an frau lagarde es muss
jetzt endlich mal der leitzins angehoben
werde handeln sie endlich wir erleben
dass sebastian zwar ein flammendes
plädoyer für eine leitzinserhöhung und
ich kann das nur voll und ganz
unterstreichen denn wir sehen ja das hat
ja ganz ganz viele verschiedene
schichten die dass dir der starrsinn der
ezb-spitze
dass das jetzt auch schon auswirkungen
hat auf den euro dollar kurs
beispielsweise und wenn der euro immer
schwächeren da sehen wir gerade dann
bedeutet das beispielsweise das öl das
importiert werden muss noch teurer wird
also die das verfahren im nullzins heizt
die inflation zusätzlich an und am ende
glaube ich ist das was du gesagt absolut
richtig das was wir jetzt sehen ist die
quittung für die zinspolitik die nicht
nur voller guard gemacht hat sondern
auch mario draghis ist die quittung für
die griechen-rettung das ist in
doppelter hinsicht eine unsoziale
politik gewesen zum einen damals für die
griechen die ja massiv sparen mussten
extrem hohe arbeitslosigkeit riesige
jugendarbeitslosigkeit viel viel armut
und die zweite soziale folge daraus das
ist das zweite ungerecht ist dass wir
das in deutschland jetzt ganz ganz viele
millionen auch spüren nämlich
beispielsweise durch hauseigentum dass
man sich selbst nicht mehr leisten kann
es ist wenn ich das sagen darf ja so
eine art große enteignungs aktion die da
stattfindet und in vielerlei hinsicht
eine zeitbombe die leute kriegen ja erst
ganz allmählich mit was da eigentlich
passiert mit dem geld das sie gespart
haben und irgendwann haben sie es dann
aber auch alle gemerkt und dann werden
wir sicher soziale unruhen bekommen von
denen wir uns heute noch keine
vorstellungen machen als folge dieser
politik ein aspekt fehlt ja noch bei dem
was sie gesagt haben was ich schon
richtig finde das eigene haus und die
eigene wohnung sind ja so die
beliebteste altersvorsorge der
mittelschicht gewesen ja und wenn das
verschwindet und es verschwindet ja im
moment dann werden leute die ihr leben
lang ganz ordentlich verdient haben in
die armut rutschen weil sie die mieten
die selbstverständlich steigen im
rentenalter nicht mehr bezahlen können
früher hat man eben relativ günstig im
eigenen hause reinen wohnung und das ist
eine große gruppe die da enteignet wird
dass es eine große gruppe die da im
alter in eine art sozialer vernichtung
geschickt wird es ist vielleicht ein
hartes wort aber wenn die leute dann
wirklich am ende eines arbeitsreichen
lebens vor dem nichts stehen dann werden
sie das da muss man kein prophet sein
dann werden sie ziemlich sauer sein mal
wer in europa eine der geringsten
eigentümer quoten haben ich glaube in
ganz europa ist nur die schweiz noch
schlechter aufgestellt also in vielen
ländern haben 80 90 prozent der
bevölkerung ein eigenes haus oder eine
eigene wohnung und dementsprechend dann
in solchen zeiten auch nicht ganz so
große probleme dann aber diejenigen die
zur miete wohnen die auch keine
eigentums immobilie haben die sind
natürlich dann auch noch besonders
getroffen und deswegen bedeutet das aus
meiner sicht das ist zwar eine
langfristige antwort aber diese auch
sehr wichtig dass die wehr ein nicht ein
volk der mieter auf dauer sein sollten
sondern wir müssen ein volk der
eigentümer werden das ist für mich auch
eine soziale frage
aber wie sie es sagen mit den
eigentümern die die die eigentum haben
die leiden natürlich auch nicht unter
der inflation die sich jetzt ergeben hat
aber man muss der ehrlichkeit auch venen
dass es früher teurer war also in
absoluten zahlen gebe ich ihnen recht
60.000 euro für eine zweizimmerwohnung
aber man musste früher wesentlich länger
für eigentum arbeiten als man es heute
muss also auch die niedrigen zinsen
machen es uns auch leichter kredit
aufzunehmen um eine wohnung zu erwerben
irgendwie steigen die bauzinsen ja auch
weil sie löhne sind auch enorm gestiegen
darf man nie vergessen als ist doch
immer so aber jetzt
sage ich
frage mich ob wir da nicht in eine in
eine ausweglose situation hinein
gesteuert sind denn was wird denn
passieren wenn die zinsen tatsächlich
wieder steigen was wird dann mit diesem
schuldenstaaten passieren ist werden die
dann nicht in eine und zusammenbrechen
und eine unglaubliche krise geraten wir
sind also in eine situation hinein
gekommen in der welt sozusagen zwischen
zwei großen krisen die wahl haben die im
süden oder die bei uns
und ich weiß irgendjemand hier eine
lösung die ezb dass ich da wir haben das
haben sie vollkommen richtig analysiert
ist ja wenn man so will eine mutlose
zentralbanken man sich an die bundesbank
die deutsche bundesbank in den 80ern
aber auch in den 90er jahren dann hatten
wir ja zum teil zinsen die ein
vielfaches 6 7 8 9 prozent leitzinsen
zum teil in 80ern ja in zweistelligen
bereich um ein vielfaches über dem lagen
gut es gibt null zins ein vielfaches von
aber als was wir jetzt haben das heißt
da hat die politik die notenbank auch
ganz klar gegen den willen der
bundesregierung politik gemacht hat
gesagt es geht mir rein um
preisstabilität und um nichts anderes
und was hat dich ezb jetzt gemacht viele
andere sie hat einen trick sie hat erst
mal richtig ganz andere themen genommen
sich plötzlich fühlte sich als grüner
investor es hat überhaupt nichts mit dem
auftrag einer zentralbank zu tun für
preisstabilität zu sorgen dann hat sie
auch noch folgendes gemacht im
vergangenen sommer sieht einfach ihr
preisstabilitätsziel das inflationsziel
geändert aus dem inflationsziel knapp
unter zwei prozent hat sie ein
mittelfristiges inflationsziel gemacht
was sie jetzt leicht die acht prozent
die wir ja fast schon haben inflation
mitnehmen lässt und nicht des jahres
deutlich noch mal über zwei prozent aber
sie sagt ja aber im jahr 2024
da rutschte wieder unter die 2 und
deswegen müssen wir nicht so gut wie
derzeit gar nichts machen also wir sehen
eine zentralbank die eigentlich zum
gehilfen zum massiven gehilfen eine
ausgabenpolitik wollen seiner
schuldenpolitik aber ihr eigenes nur
eines ziel aufgegeben hat und das ist
echt bitter vor allem diejenigen die
nicht viel geld haben die können ja
häufig gar nicht sich die frage stelle
nach investiere ich jetzt mal ein oder
zwei immobilien und dann wachsen
vielleicht die der wächst der wert der
immobilien mit der inflation mit das ja
der gedanke den der häufig geäußert wird
sondern die sitzen da die haben das geld
auf dem konto designer für eine
immobilie reicht es nicht aktien sind
auch es kann gerade dann für ältere
leute weil man ehren aktien ja auch
investiert um langfristig vermögen
aufzubauen und die rentner die haben
dann keine andere möglichkeit als das
geld auf dem konto zu lassen und durch
eine inflation von sieben oder acht
prozent gibt es dann einen massiven
kaufkraftverlust und das merken ja
gerade die rentner auch wenn sie im
supermarkt gehen und lebensmittelkarten
aber setzt sich dann nicht die frage
schuldigen hartenstein ist die ezb
mutlos oder ist sie einfach zu abhängig
ich habe mutlos abhängig also das ist
mario draghi der vorgänger von frau
lagarde hat ja immer die regierung in
europa aufgefordert hat ja gleichzeitig
nullzins am ende auf null gesenkt 20/16
hat gesagt aber jetzt müsst ihr reform
machen jetzt muss der reform machen aber
eher wie ein ausstiegs zielgenau der nie
gesagt das machen wir jetzt bis 2019
reihe jahre lang und für allem und in
der zeit müsst ihr was tun bin nicht da
habt ihr pech gehabt garbsen wo es heißt
man hat sich daran gewöhnt also sowie
der drogensüchtige sich an die drogen
gewöhnt hat hat man sich dann irgendwann
die niedrigzinsen gewöhnt als sogar an -
zinsen ich weiß auch noch im
bundestagswahlkampf robert habeck der
hat gesagt wunderbar die zinssituation
jesu super nehmen wir über 500
milliarden euro auf um zum beispiel in
klimaschutz zu investieren so dass das
nicht von irgendjemanden im wahrsten
sinne des wortes bezahlt werden musste
spielte in den diskussionen gar keine
rolle mehr sondern alle angesagt als ob
dein geld wie manna vom himmel fällt man
kann das einfach aufnehmen und punkt und
dass das ein irrglaube ist und dass das
gerade diejenigen im land bezahlen
müssen die sowieso nicht viel geld haben
das ist das was jetzt immer mehr ins
bewusstsein der menschen kommt und ich
befürchte auch dass wir mit diesem
problem nicht nur in den nächsten
monaten leben müssen sondern
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten jahren
und deswegen auch meine forderung die
zinsen die müssten jetzt stark angehoben
werden das wäre gerade im sinne der
menschen die nicht so viel geld haben
aber es gibt kein nochmaliger grage zu
bezwingen noch mal die frage wie
realistisch ist das wenn mal gesetzt den
fall dass die südländer so verschuldet
sind dass sie mit höheren zinsen einfach
nicht klar kommen das problem wird nicht
zusammenbrechen lassen gigantische
hilfszahlungen oder eine monster
inflation nummer 10 ist und b oder
europa ja die eurozone ist in einem auch
international wettbewerb das heißt wenn
in anderen regionen der welt auch die
zinsen jetzt angehoben werden wie zum
beispiel in den usa dann kann die ezb
auch nicht sagen das interessiert uns
nicht weil sonst irgendwann auch nur
noch sehr wenige investoren in europa es
ist auch nicht ihre aufgabe
die verschuldung irgendwie der angriff
zu einem andern preisstabilität das ist
ihre aufgabe
einzig und allein martenstein sprach
gerade von der angst vor sozialen
unruhen kurzes kurze antwort von infra
frischen teilen sie das dass wir
möglicherweise einigen jahren aufgrund
der politik der ezb soziale unruhen
haben das ist durchaus möglich ja also
wir kommen ja aus einer sehr
wohlhabenden zeit und jetzt bröckelt das
also viele leute oder die menschen
machen sich sorgen über die
schuldenaufnahme und und und das
demografische problem da kommen wir
später noch darauf zu sprechen das lässt
sich auch nicht negieren oder abwenden
da kommen noch ordentlich probleme auf
und so also